Poppy Harlow: Battlefield 5 update!
An Important update for T Series....
But most importantly of all...
puddles [?]
*Chair Fail*
[Pew News Intro]
Good Evening!
I'm Poppy Harlow
The most NEWS person,
In the NEWS
Our first story comes from Battlefield 5.
This is an update from last week.
Apparently Battlefield 5 had a really bad amount of pre-orders
-lagging 85% behind Call of Duty
*Pewds Groan* That sucks...*yes it does*
Some people-
A bunch of Idiots- (yeah)
I'm not supposed to add my opinion but...
said this was because Red Dead Redemption was coming out.....
.......is because Call of Duty is coming out
It's just over saturated in October
MMMHMMMHMMMM
The true chads knew what the reason was behind this...
and of course it was because
...the chief design officer of battlefield said
"If you don't like our trailer,
you are uneducated!"
*Meme review clap*
and then he mysteriously left the company,
as you do, two months before a release...
and I try to explain in the video
why I think people didn't like the trailer,
myself included.
Okay? . . .
they have done really bad at- job at
marketing battlefield so far
and I broke that down
but I still saw a lot of people commenting.
sssss...
"I don't know It doesn't look like a bionic arm,  just like a prosthetic."
I called it a bionic arm,
It's a prosthetic a-arm
I know the difference. I just misspoke. Ok.
*Skkksss*
We don't get our education about how wars were from games. Sure, they can do that, but it's not their job
It's a school's job. I couldn't give less F's about what's in Battlefield.*Christian channel pewds*
I wasn't at the war and I wouldn't play to relive it either. Yes, the trailer just being a statement is kind of dumb
However, people going numb over that just as dumb. So-the-basically you're calling me dumb for saying this trailer is dumb
*Pewds thinking about his channel * *Pewds thinking about his life*
Anyway, it seemed like so many people didn't understand what I was talking about. So I will reiterate just to make this point
Crystal-clear. Okay. This is important. Stop. Okay. I'm not even gonna pretend that the battlefield 5 trailer
is not the most important thing in the entire universe
You have to understand, companies aren't mortal beings. Okay, they will say and do whatever that will bring them more sales. *$399!*
They don't think like human beings,  because they're not humans. The problem I have and a lot of people have with the trailer is not
the fact that there's a woman in it people aren't going
RRREEEEEEEEEEEEE
There's a woman. No one cares. Okay, and to be 100% clear. I don't have a problem with women in power
In fact, I encourage it, okay? You want to do that, great! Good for you
But when you're simulating a war, okay, they know that they have to work within a certain framework
Okay, if they didn't people would get pissed off and that's what happened here
yes, you can say oh, well, there were no flamethrowers in the Battle of Shvacobol  and
No one cares about that. Yes, you're talking about objects here. We're talking about people we're talking about human beings
We're talking about history if battlefield 5 said they're doing a world war game where Swedes are fighting Nazis in the trenches
People would comment about it in the same way saying well that didn't really happen did it and then their response would be oh well
actually
8,000 Swedish people did fight in the war so checkmate. It's like that's not the point
Yes, there were women in World War two, but it's not a plausible scenario
so if you want to make the statement or having a woman in power as the cover of the game and in the trailer as
The main focus I think it's great
It's annoying that I have to call it a statement
but it's a statement because it's done so
Painfully obviously and so poorly if you wanted to put a female soldier on the cover
Why not use something that was actually, I don't know plausible. Okay.
Let me just acknowledge: good intention, terrible execution. That's what this is.
Now apparently EA
Delayed the release of battlefield until November. I think it's probably a good move be honest
this did cost the stocks of EA to drop a lot and
and uhh...
I'm gonna keep developing the story and see how it goes because it's a-- it's interesting to me *and you get content*
PewDiePie-- my favourite YouTube channel. I'm not supposed to give my opinion
I'm just Poppy Harlow
But my favourite YouTube channel is being overtaken by this channel T series
You probably heard about this already
But later this year PewDiePie will no longer be the biggest channel on YouTube
It will be overrun by the channel T series
Now Pewdiepie bravely
Challenged T series to a fight to the death and they have yet to respond to his request
What a bunch of cowards. PewDiePie has gathered a lot of support by Mr. Beast
For example, Leon Lush: We don't stand a chance against the population of India
Sometimes is not about who's going to win
It's about being on the right side of history
The all-inclusive channel... or the Indians. Huh!?
War... war is coming, T-series
Be aware.
Now, this was covered uuhh by... of course...
*giggle*
The verge. The VERGE AND the POLYOGN, same company! It's the same company owned by Vox, interesting.
They're the only ones covering this
Now. Okay, firs-- let it be clear. I don't care. Ok.
I know that's a
false statement because if I say I don't care I am saying I care enough to say that I care and then just go on
And it doesn't make any sense. I know. The thing is I have expressed that
I don't want to be the number one channel on YouTube for a long time
Okay. I would prefer if someone else passes me if T-- if T series was an actual individual and not a company
I would gladly congratulate them on becoming number one. It genuinely doesn't bother me
There are ARE already channels bigger than me, but no one's talking about that.
You have Music, Gaming, Sports and YouTube Movies
I'm technically the fifth biggest YouTube *laugh*
Now, of course!
Polygon EHH They always know how to grind my gears *incoherent cry*
So instead of talking about this I wanted to bring up the point that they bring up in this
Uhhhh
article where polygon brings up this video from MatPat, which says
Ironically, what helped Kjellberg become the "King of YouTube" as explained by Matt Patrick in the video
Kjellberg managed to reach audiences in countries like Sweden, Italy, France--
France! Ok.
And the UK while also building up a fan base in the United States
And I've heard this argument so many times. It's just one of those
Things that people keep saying and then it's so-- it suddenly takes on a truth on its own
Because Matt did this video which is a really good video
I still hate it and I think he should delete it because he made this speculation:
but why this Let's Play channel?
There's thousands out there. Well, there's one other reason the algorithm loves PewDiePie
He's international. You see YouTube promotes channels locally
If you live in California
Your videos will be served up in California
More frequently than in other areas of the US and if you live in the US your videos will stay in the US
Until you gather enough views from other countries to merit them sharing your stuff there
PewDiePie has a unique advantage over most other channels because YouTube considers his channel
Swedish since he started it when he was living in Sweden. Makes sense. Since then he's moved
Meaning that he lives and uploads from Italy, but he also speaks English
So since YouTube promotes locally, he was able to gather a strong Swedish following in a market where there was less competition
But now that he uploads from Italy he gets promoted there. And since YouTube is most heavily used in english-speaking nations
He had a much easier time crossing into the US and UK
Than a channel from here would have doing the reverse.
Ok, Matt. You had no idea what you were talking about *slams headphones*
This is such a dumb video and I hate- I'd-- like i-if you want to piss me off just say "Oh well pewdiepie
he just grew because he moved countries"
The reason this annoys me especially is because it's the complete opposite
When I started off doing YouTube
There was a lot of ways to poke through the system
There was a lot of ways you can deliberately do to make your channel grow quicker
that was... uh...
Technically not allowed but YouTube didn't really stop anyone from doing it.
One of those things would be that you can set your channel
Country in your setting you can set your country to anything
and YouTube will acknowledge your channel as that
It wasn't location-based. It was purely based on the settings and back in 2013
The front page of YouTube was a big part of growing your channel. It was probably how you
Gather the most subscribers if you got on the front page of YouTube, that was a massive deal
And yes, each front page on each country was different
so a Swedish-- so Sweden did have their own front page just like
America has their own front page. Just like there was also a worldwide front page
So what people did was they would set their channel as Swedish
Even though they were American so the front page of Sweden was nothing but American channels
Abusing the system so they would get views from Sweden when they weren't even from Sweden
While people who were Swedish
DIDN'TGROWFROMIT *little chuckle*
It annoys me because I was so frustrated by a-- by this back in 2013
I kind of pride myself that I've never abused youtube's system to grow my channel.
It's one of those things where I've seen
while growing my own channel a lot of other people do
and benefiting from it as well.
So when people make these statements saying, "Oh, he just grow his channel because you know,
He moved from Italy to UK to Sweden and that gave him that boost. Its
It takes away the value of all the work
I put into this channel working my ass off the last seven years, and yes it pisses me off
So this whole thing couldn't be more false
But it's one of those things I keep being reiterated as true.
It-- despite me debunking it. It's annoying because people take Matt's
Speculation as some form of truth and here it is five years later being reported as true
I don't think I deserved 65 million subscribers. I genuinely don't. It makes no sense to me.*thats why you are the chosen one*
I don't want to be the biggest channel. Like I said, I don't care... I don't care
I just want to be making videos, do my own thing. Everything else is just annoying
Dealing with this stuff is  annoying
It's kind of fun too okay, but it's annoying.
*small laugh*
None of this makes any sense to me like-- uh...
Why my channel got so big. It doesn't make sense to me either I have no idea
I was the least popular guy in school.
I don't understand it still, I still think I'm really-- there's nothing special about my content
So I understand that people want a reason for it.
Another thing that's annoying about this article is that
Or at least in the verge
if you ever want to control a narrative if you ever wanted something to seem a certain way?
All you gotta do is just hand select a few comments.
Look at this. You can't just hand pick comments
I don't know why they keep doing it. Well, I know why
Brofist army, where are you?!
You dare challenge the king?
Alexa. Delete this channel.
*wheezy laugh*
War is coming... prepare yourself T-series
*Alexa mumbles something incoherently in background*
No one asked you!
T-series' videos have recently been
mostly overrun by swarms of PewDiePie related comments
Some of which encourage people to down-vote or to report channels uploads
So they trying to make it seem like yeah alright it's all a bunch of NINE-YEAR-OLDS, which it is, by the way
Spamming this poor channel, this poor channel. Okay.
I think-- I think the video
that gets
15 million views in two days will be okay
I think they will survive
T-SERIES
accept my challenge to the death
Until then the swarm of nine-year-olds will keep coming after you and the verge and
Anyone that dare challenge us.
That's right. I pledge my allegiance to PewDiePie.*and me too*
Sorry, we're out of time
I'm Poppy Harlow.
Thank you for smashing like on this video. It supports this channel along with hitting the sponsor button
Arigato Gozaimasu~
And I'll see you guys next week. I'm Poppy Harlow- *pop sound*
KABOOM *DESTRUCTION AND EXPLOSIONSSSSS*
*PEW NEWS OUTRO*